hey guys welcome to another these things
that you've been hopefully watching
before anyway I'm here with Brizzy
voices yeah
she's got an amazing channel she does
love impressions and voices and recently
today youtubers impressions and I made
the cut she's on it she impersonated me
and I thought I was watching one of my
own video cast which is just like so fun
yeah because I until I watch that I had
been watching all of my own videos
remember aunt Hannah on it too
yeah I thought it would be really fun to
have her on here today to not do any
voices instead we're gonna be talking
about fashions and summer trends things
like style fabrics textiles trends
fashions styles
now tip relevant the tangible items
curtains raising voices and I have come
up with a few things that we think are
going to be huge trends this summer
they're going to share with you so
you're ahead of the curve okay and you
can tell your friends and be like I
already I already know when they start
wearing or doing these things
okay the cool print yeah you're gonna be
the trendsetter rather than the trend
yeah I think that inhalers as jewelry
are gonna be you yeah because you need
them to breathe but why not make them
into something fashionable so you have
it very accessible and if you don't need
an inhaler to breathe you're just like
showing a sign of like support to your
fellow like yeah long list people also
beach spray paint then they look super
cute oh I got especially glitter spray
paint yeah it kind of looks like a
Tetris piece and video games
they're now very hip very
and great Mother's Day gift fantastic
except Mother's Day just passed great
fathers make it great Father's Day gift
Father's Day it might have passed by the
time this has gone up I don't know when
Father's Day is maybe like great Labor
Day gift great how are you yes ok
birthday what do you got what's really
gonna be in this season hair white is
reverse Mohawk but you know how people
shave their hair in Mohawks neck oh I'm
so hip and boldly I'm being brave what's
really brave is just shaving where the
Mohawk would be and leaving everything
else also it's very like cooling for the
top of your head summer to breathe you
can even put little racecars on it like
rhinestones you lit whatever you want
yeah do the reverse another big thing is
gonna be naval hats not Navy inspired
hats
yep hats for your naval like if you're a
female or male on your outside like
sunbathing you can and you have a little
top hat over your belly button people
gonna be like oh my god that's classy
that's just obligated that's now that
person is super hip you can get really
cute ones éclairs they're already all
over the place yeah you can also crack
them yourselves very easily you can make
a top hat out of the toilet paper roll
and like some construction paper not
waterproof no I learned that the hard
way
you can do all kinds of hats you can do
like baseball hats beanies other hats so
the world is your oyster it is speaking
of crafting accessories what's gonna be
really in this season it's tin foil
jewelry the possibilities are endless
you just get a sheet of tin foil okay
and you mold it into whatever you want
anything it's like what if this gonna be
instant statement
right there and so cheap so cheap and
it's summer this tinfoil will help you
tan in no time yeah you are your own
rotisserie chicken yeah you can make
necklaces earrings bracelets rings shoes
anklets anything toe rings girl oh
bloody me boy you're dangerous look at
that you even a little crown yeah you go
to the been fair just feel like I'm a
futuristic fairy yeah you look like an
alien princess oh my god I feel hippin
now next we have braided eyelashes oh my
gosh yes I mean hair braids have been in
for a really long time and there's been
a lot of variations and a lot of like
new ways to do the traditional braid
this is the newest way you braid your
eyelashes there are a lot of salons that
have been doing this especially in Los
Angeles you just go in and you ask your
beautician or whatever I want to get my
eyelash and spray it and she'll probably
be like we don't do that and then you
say yes you do and then she'll say like
seriously no we don't do that and then
you say stop belittling me I know you'd
do this great my eyelashes and then you
sit down and don't leave it's so trendy
and hip like the salons have to be
really secretive and pretend like they
don't know but I really do yeah there's
a secret word that you have to go in and
say to the beautician and it's tan T tan
T paint paint yeah it's a phrase
actually they'll get it yeah and then
you're gonna have the most beautiful
braided eyelashes that anyone has ever
seen well you heard it here first so
make sure that you get it on that trend
the next thing that's really in this
season is crying yes all of our stars
just came out everyone's going to see it
because they want to solve
they want their heartbroken they want
tears streaming down their face yeah and
if you are not in the theater watching
The Fault in Our Stars just put on globs
of not waterproof mascara and just slap
your face with water because that tears
stain from mascara is so in yeah
everyone loves crying this somewhere
yeah everyone loves looking vulnerable
like feeling like you need someone walk
I should like ask you if you need help
super trendy super super trendy so you
guys have heard of catkins
before you guys know what captains are I
have no idea
it's a muumuu dress a captain a Captain
Hook a muumuu dress but this isn't
instead of past hands were doing cowl
tans so it's mainly tanning yourself so
you look like you have the spots of a
cow all over your body cow hands are
huge in and the way I like to do it is I
like to just cut out shapes of like
amoeba esque looking things and just lay
them tape them on my body my naked body
while I lay out in the Sun and then just
sort of like sit on my hands and knees
and eat grass for a little while after
the tan has really set in it's so cute
brendi I mean there's a lot of
vegetarians out there and I know that
you don't like me but why not look like
the meat you don't want to eat exactly
just look scrumptious and tempting even
if people resist eating you tomorrow yep
okay my last trend is cheek bones fierce
as Maleficent yeah so you could get
surgery you know I always recommend
permanent body altering surgeries for
seasonal trends but you can't afford it
just go with the old oh yes you can like
David Blaine of The Illusionist I'm
ready so just grab some black eyeliner
suck in your cheeks like a putting on
bronzer and just shrimp
instant fierce as an Alexis oh my god I
feel like Melissa fed or MLMs if Alexa
I feel like student from the movie or
that I got in a gang fight yeah those
cheekbones could cut steel well there
you go guys
there are 2014 summer trends from me and
Brizzy voices I hope that this is
helpful for you and all of your friends
make sure that you do everything that
we've said so that you can become
popular and legs by the people around
you it's different
yeah what else is there in life no the
only way you're valued is based on your
popularity with as many people as
possible so I hope you enjoy make sure
that you go over to Brizzy voices
channel begin and we got your super fun
video over there and also she's just a
wonderful human being oh super talented
so make sure you go check it out guys
that I don't know